we know gas prices are high right now we
know how it affects you
it affects us we have started a campaign
in cooperation with conoco to help gift
you a good day let's take a look at how
i surprised one lucky customer
[Music]
i met fabi at conoco how expensive is to
try and fill up all the time it is
35 every time i have to fill up it used
to be 20
she said it's hard making sacrifices
you're forced to get gas to go to work
in the grocery store there's really no
cutting corners right now we know how
expensive it is for you and for everyone
else to pay for their gas at channel 8
and conoco we are actually going to gift
you
a good day we're going to help pay for
your gas today cool that's very awesome
thank you so much channeling for doing
this for everybody you know even though
um
this is just such a crazy time but thank
you so much for because i'm pretty sure
anybody will appreciate this thank you
for doing this
had a great time surprising fabby there
you never know when you could be next
just keep an eye out for the good day
team which we are all a part of same
time on wednesday we're going to give to
someone else a very good day